today's episode is sponsored by blinka
Stu the app that lets you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blink it's totally
free and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blink is comm slash David
Pakman I put the link right below this
video let's talk today about the concept
of the lesser of two evils are you evil
if you choose the lesser of two evils or
should you abstain altogether from being
involved in such a choice now of course
the context of all of this is that there
are people saying they're not going to
vote for Joe Biden instead of Donald
Trump because Joe Biden is merely the
lesser of two evils there are people who
see both Biden and Trump as evils
although maybe two different degrees and
voting for any evil would not be okay
for them so they might abstain or they
might vote third party or right someone
in or whatever the case may be another
way that some are saying it is those who
are focusing in on the sexual assault
component of the current political race
there are people who write to me and say
David are you just saying I should
choose which sexual assault or I want
I either vote for a sexual assault or
with one allegation against them or a
sexual assault or with 26 that's not a
good choice for me I'm going to opt out
so let's really think this through and
take it in pieces there's this first
question of just arguing like is Biden
evil or is Biden not that good or like
what what what exactly is the
characterization of Biden in this
context I'm gonna argue that it doesn't
matter to me it's a distraction to say
is Biden good or simply less evil than
Donald Trump once you grant that Biden
is better than Trump if you don't then
vote for Trump then there's not even a
conversation if you think crumbs better
vote for Trump that's clear but once you
grant Biden is better than Trump I don't
think it matters whether Biden is less
evil or good for the purposes of the
conversation we're going to have today
secondly and this is really important
the concept of opting out because you
can't vote for evil
there's no opting out here folks if
you're an American and you are allowed
to vote
there is no opting out you can choose
not to cast a ballot but from a left of
Trump perspective either way you're
participating you're influencing you
have a stake and and you are you're
affecting the outcome whether you cast a
ballot or not there are people making
themselves sort of feel okay about not
voting for Biden by simply saying I'm
opting out I don't like the choices so
I'm not going to participate in a
literal sense you aren't taking the act
of voting and going and doing it but
you're not opting out of the process if
you vote for Trump that's obviously a
vote against Biden if you don't vote at
all and believe Biden is less bad than
Trump but not good enough for you to
vote for him you're still helping Trump
with one vote it's a vote that Trump
does not need to overcome in order to be
re-elected so let's really cut through
the BS here Biden being evil or not
isn't relevant if we agree he's better
than Trump for our purposes today that's
all that matters opting out and being a
non actor in the process as the
rejection of both candidates unless you
renounce your citizenship and aren't
allowed to vote you have a vote whether
you use it or not you are participating
and your actions are part of the
ultimate consequence so given all of
that this is actually quite simple if
you were put in a room with two buttons
one button kills ten people and one
button kills a million people and if you
say I'm not going to press a button
someone else can press the button for me
is there any question that you are
acting in a way that is improper is
there any question that you should
obviously press the button given that
one of these two buttons is going to be
pressed that saves nine hundred and
ninety-nine thousand nine hundred and
ninety people right nine nine nine nine
nine zero people of course you should
press that button that would be choosing
between the lesser of two evils killing
ten people is bad killing 1 million
people
is also bad and I would argue it is
worse but it actually again doesn't
matter whether you're choosing between
two evils because think about a slightly
different scenario than the one I just
gave you you're in the same room there
are also two buttons one button kills a
million people and the other kills no
one and resurrects one person it brings
back someone that died of a car accident
okay
imagine that isn't the right action
obvious in both cases resurrect one
person versus kill ten million
kill ten versus kill ten million
whatever the numbers are right in either
case these are the choices and if you
say leave it up to chance leave it up to
other people or I can take the action
that I know is the preferable action of
course I take the preferable action
anytime now how do you justify taking
any action that could let other people
press the kill a million button in
either case I don't know how you justify
that this is why the debate about is
Biden sort of good but not that good
vs. is Biden less bad than Trump it's
irrelevant
there is no responsible way to say I'm
gonna let other people choose and I
won't put in my vote for the less bad or
better option but if that was the full
analysis I would be doing a disservice
to this discussion there are
philosophical structures that would
defend not pressing any button so I've
sort of given you a more utilitarian
perspective but let's consider for a
second the philosophy of Immanuel Kant's
contain ISM German philosopher from
mostly the 18th century died in in the
first few years of the 19th century I
believe you could certainly take a look
at Con Thien ISM which is focused not on
end goals like I'm looking at the end
goal when I say if ten or a million are
going to die let me do what I can to
make it ten instead of a million contin
ISM instead of focusing on the end goal
would deal more with one's duty and
acting in accordance with underlying
principles so if we focus on this lesser
of two evils idea and
look at it in terms of the principle one
could have a content aligned principle
of I'm not going to vote for bad people
that I'm only going to exercise my vote
when I have someone good to vote for
because of a principle I'm not going to
do the utilitarian focus on the end goal
of killing fewer people I'm going to
justify not pressing either button
because it would violate a principle of
mine rather than focusing on the harm
reduction utilitarian component but
that's a fair argument that that would
be right out of content ISM I believe
that even in this case even in this
strict Conte and defense of the non vote
to adhere to a principle I think it
still falls apart because in the case of
voting or not voting in the United
States both actions are a form of
participation once again whether you
vote or not you're participating either
way and what I mean by that is that the
act of voting in and of itself like the
caste filling out your ballot mailing it
in whatever it is in a moral sense
neutral right just filling out a piece
of paper you're either filling out the
piece of paper or you're not filling out
the piece of paper but once you
understand that either way you're
participating in deciding the outcome
you're no less of a participant by not
voting you are no more adhering to the
principle that you are trying to adhere
to in this content sense by not voting
whether you vote for Trump or merely
don't get in the way of Trump by not
voting you are still participating
because voting is the right that you
have as an American you are either way
participating in the outcome and thus
the non vote might make people feel like
they're opting out over principles and
having no impact choosing not to
participate but in reality you are just
as much of a participant whether you
vote or not and thus even a conte and
ethic of adhering to principles rather
than focusing on utilitarian end goals
fails to justify a non vote in this case
let me know where I'm going wrong I look
forward to the discussion the FBI has
served a search warrant on
public and Senator Richard burr for his
stock trades around the corona virus
pandemic you might remember that Richard
Burr was one of the senators exposed to
making very convenient stock trades
right after being briefed about the
coming pandemic but before that
knowledge was public an investigation is
underway federal agents have now seized
any number of elements from Richard Burr
including his cell phone
recalled that Richard Burr is the
senator who sold a bunch of stock on
February 13th this was when the Senate
Intelligence Committee was already
regularly being briefed about the coming
pandemic Trump publicly was downplaying
it and Republicans publicly were
downplaying it as well and a whole bunch
of those shares of stock lost massive
amounts of value in the weeks that
followed as the effect of coronavirus
hit the markets and Richard Burr was
able to avoid significant financial
losses by these traits now do I think
that this investigation is serious
because after all we're talking about
Donald Trump's Attorney General William
bars Justice Department this is one of
the most politically biased Justice
Department's that we've seen in a long
time do I really believe that they are
going to go hard against Republican
senators I hate to say it but my
instinct is that this is basically a
show and I'll tell you what what the
counter counterfactual would be in a
moment so okay yeah big you know to get
a warrant you have to have already done
a bunch of work to convince a judge that
there's probable cause that Richard Burr
committed a crime I get it yes to serve
a search warrant to a sitting u.s.
senator it means it was approved in the
Justice Department at the highest levels
but I have a very difficult time
believing that this is going to go very
far now one thing I will mention is that
if this gets to more senators then maybe
it is serious because Richard Burr was
not the only one we had Republican
senator Kelly Lafleur from Georgia
dumped huge amounts of stock bought
shares of Citrix which makes telework
software one thing I want to remind you
of because it's relevant here is insider
trade trading verses the stock Act
there's some confusion between insider
trading from an SEC perspective and
violations of the stock Act when we talk
about insider trading in general you're
typically
trading a company's stock because of
non-public information usually about
that company it's not always illegal it
depends on when you make the trade what
the information is a whole bunch of
other factors and it's governed by the
Securities and Exchange Commission the
SEC the stock Act is a specific piece of
legislation that applies to members of
Congress it applies to the trading
activities of members of Congress
specifically this was needed because
members of Congress could trade on
inside information that was not about a
particular company but it was more
related to non-public briefings
intelligence related to could be
national security foreign policy or
whatever else it would potentially not
be illegal per the SCC's insider trading
laws in some cases something that would
be trading that violates the stock Act
important to understand so the stock Act
was meant to deal with that it was
passed in 2012 it was then weakened in
2013 now this is really interesting the
stock Act passed in the Senate 96 to 396
2/3 of the three people to vote against
it one happens to be Richard Burr the
exact Republican senator that we're
talking about today now let me mention
one other thing this is very cynical
there were many Republican senators
involved in this apparent insider
trading around coronavirus so far it's
only Richard Burr who has been served a
warrant it just so happens that Richard
Burr is the only one of the senators who
allegedly did this insider trading who
signed on to a Senate report because
there again he's part of the Senate
Intelligence Committee which found Trump
Russia collusion he signed his name to
it is Burr being targeted as retribution
while so far Kelly Lafleur and the
others have not been I don't know the
Trump Justice Department which wrongly
summarized robert molars report as total
exoneration that was a lie recently
decided they didn't want to prosecute
Michael Flynn who pleaded guilty they
said yeah yeah we're not gonna prosecute
him and they've now figured out how to
get Paul Manafort
out of prison which we'll talk about on
the bonus show I would not put it past
this Justice Department to target
Richard Burr and not the others because
of his signing on to the Trump Russia
report that the Senate Intelligence
Committee put out that's what we know so
far we will follow it let me know what
you think i'm on twitter at depatment
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read ten books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka stand what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blink as' to
get a sample first just think how much
you can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire nonfiction book in
just 15 minutes I recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash david pakman I've put the
link right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are Angelina
Tartini oh and Lisa Allen Angelina and
Lisa thank you for your support I also
want to say thanks
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day it is Karin Gossage who has been
a member for almost five years get all
of the member benefits including the
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show as well as the members only
bonus show by signing up at join
pakman.com it is quick and easy and it
is almost free almost free if you use
the coupon code 2020 now which will save
you 66 percent the david pakman show
subreddit is approaching a huge
milestone 20,000 subscribers you can
find it at david pakman.com slash our
EDD IT couple interesting posts from
this morning lime guy asked how many of
you are friends with trumpets do you
think politics matters with friends this
is something I've never come to a
conclusion on though I find people who
believe really dumb crap can be annoying
to me like Trump apologists you know for
me the conflicts with conservative
acquaintances and friends are you are
rarely about politics themselves but
it's about something indirectly related
to their worldview so like we rarely
argue about electoral politics or
abortion or stuff like that but what
gets irritating and tends to cause
conflict is that their political views
are linked to a generally bizarre
worldview which might include you know
aggressive skepticism of science or
conspiratorial thinking about
uncontroversial institutions or whatever
the case may be so in my experience the
difficulty with acquaintances colleagues
friends that whose politics are
different is not so much about the
politics of electoral decisions so to
speak but more just that like their
politics are just part of a worldview
that to me is difficult to be around
and very often I end up sort of opting
out I'm talking about you know pretty
radical people here like some kind of
moderate centrist where we disagree on
on fiscal policy it's not really a huge
deal but but that's typically what
happens though the arguments aren't
actually about you know social security
or abortion or gay marriage or whatever
the case may be also posted by reflex
point is a very interesting section of
sam harris interviewing andrew yang on
two issues joe biden's cognitive state
as well as Tara Reed I encourage people
to check this out I tend to have the
same perspective as Andrew yang here he
explains when it comes to Joe Biden's
cognitive state that listen he's 78 and
and thus he is a different person
cognitively to some degree as he was
when he debated Paul Ryan eight almost
nine years ago but that Andrew yang has
spent time with him and Joe Biden is
cognitively okay and that all of the
stuff that we're seeing is is relatively
overblown that goes with what I'm seeing
from the mental health experts that I
talked to you and the neurologists that
I've spoken to I would not doubt for a
second that Joe Biden is not slowed down
compared to who he was 9 12 15 20 years
ago he's nearly 80 years old and this is
something that happens but I concur with
Andrew yang on that and react also says
that he does not think that the Tara
Reid story is going to explode and be
the prevailing narrative over the next
few months with Joe Biden and I also
agree with that and I've explained why
earlier this week so check out that
video if you haven't seen it and then
lastly here is a question about the
Ahmad R burry case a user named HOH H
231 says is it too soon to talk about
how the father and son who lynched the
black jogger in Georgia will likely be
found innocent I don't know that I would
even go into characterizing it as a
lynching or not and debating whether the
guy was jogging or not everybody's
disputing every one of these facts I
hate to say it I really do but if you
said David you've got a
do those guys end up being found guilty
of any felonies or not I say probably
not that's probably the way that I would
bet and we have to let the justice
system run its course of course the
problem is when we don't trust the
justice system to properly adjudicate
certain types of cases becomes more and
more difficult to do that but if you
said David you just you got a bet you
got a bet on either they are found not
guilty or guilty of some minor
misdemeanor that they plea down to or
these individuals plead or are found
guilty to felonies I bet that they're
not found guilty of felonies okay
remember you can join the discussion at
david pakman.com slash read it it is
free to subscribe and nearly 20,000 of
you have already done that Donald Trump
was interviewed this morning on Fox News
by brown-nosing sycophant Maria
Bartiromo
she was actually a pretty damn good
financial journalist 20 years ago I used
to watch her when I was getting into
stock trading early in high school and
now she is just a trump suck-up on the
Fox Business Network this interview
aired this morning but it was previously
recorded as I gather and the interview
was an absolutely unmitigated house of
horrors I want to go through some of the
most bizarre and disturbing moments with
you we could spend all day just looking
at this interview but I want to pick
just two important moments of Maria
Bartiromo
gave Trump a softball interview like she
always does and yet Trump is so clueless
his ignorant is so lethally weaponized
that even Maria Bartiromo couldn't save
him with softball questions so let's
take a look now to get this first thing
out of the way the goal posts are again
being moved on the coronavirus death
toll now Trump is talking about we're
going to have more than a hundred
thousand deaths and that is a great
victory because of how much worse it
could have been check this out and look
at how casually Trump has doubled the
expected number of deaths from just
three weeks ago and yet it's still
calling it a victory thanks to him we're
going to lose over a hundred thousand
perhaps in this country now in all
fairness that's at the bottom level of
the scale we were to lost two million we
were
more if we did it a different way but
you're talking about a hundred thousand
more a little bit less more who knows
it's a terrible thing no so that can't
be replaced we're spending trillions of
dollars on all of the damage
economically financially that it's
caused so it it is a terrible thing it's
just an incredible thing so he says
that's at the bottom we could have lost
more than two million people so there
are two important takeaways here
yesterday we did a debunking about we're
now testing as much as South Korea per
capita important to understand the the
genesis of that disinformation I want
you to now understand the genesis of
this two million thing that we hear a
couple things that are important to know
number one the goal posts have been
moved into the locker room and they will
soon be out in the parking lot for a
month or longer Trump was talking about
we may lose 60,000 people and that's
going to be a really great job that
we'll have done we blew past 60,000
deaths so Trump starts talking about
listen we could lose seventy or eighty
thousand people we hit 70 and Trump
started talking about could be ninety to
a hundred thousand now Trump is
cavalierly and casually saying I'm gonna
lose more than a hundred thousand people
and as long as he always predicts a
number slightly larger than what we have
eventually he's going to be right
eventually he will say you know we're
gonna lose 200,000 maybe and we'll get
to 195 and he'll say we stayed under it
forty percent of the country Falls for
it forty percent of the country will
hear this and believe Trump knows what
he's talking about no matter how many
times he shifts the number more
importantly here's what I really want
people to understand this comparison of
the death toll always to 2.2 or 2.5
million the deaths we could have had if
Donald Trump didn't act understand that
two million deaths is if literally
nothing is done now this would be
impossible because governors do excuse
me do things there is not going to be
any scenario where governors were doing
nothing in fact the governors did stuff
before Trump did we saw stay at home
orders and starting to quarantine and
and the like at the
state-level before Trump did anything so
when Trump says understand we're two
million comes from two million is we
have 331 million people in the country
70% of the country gets the virus that
would get us to hurt immunity if 70
percent got the virus that means about
230 million people get the virus we
expect an infection fatality rate not a
case fatality rate an infection fatality
rate of about 1% 1% of 231 million is
2.3 million so that is literally no
mitigation so when Trump says listen
we're gonna lose a hundred thousand
instead of two million thanks to me it's
a worthless comparison that says nothing
at all about Donald Trump's response the
important point is were now at 85
thousand deaths were expected to hit a
hundred thousand in about a week or ten
days the numbers will continue climbing
but Trump will claim victory no matter
the death number because he has set 2.2
2.3 million as the bar that he is
keeping us below next clip clip of Trump
exhibiting such a poor understanding of
trade economics and manufacturing and
foreign policy that he actually says if
we end our relationship with China
our financial relationship our
relationship of trade we would save five
hundred billion dollars I'm gonna play
the clip Trump seems to think if we just
we stop importing and exporting with
China we quote save 500 billion take a
look at this
these pulpit is Xi Jinping I have a very
good relationship but I just right now I
don't want to speak to him because you
know senator cotton was saying maybe we
should be limiting the amount of visas
that we give to students who want to
study things like there are many things
and AI there are many things we could do
we could do things we could cut off the
whole relationship now if you did what
would happen you'd say 500 million
dollars if you cut off the whole
relationship look at what point does it
and I said this for years I said it with
other countries also you know China's
not the only country ripping us off this
is one of the
most incoherent things that Trump has
actually said in his presidency and I'm
gonna explain to you why first there's
this idea that we we save 500 billion I
believe what Trump is talking about is
our trade deficit with China as recently
as a couple of years ago I had trouble
finding the numbers from from last year
but a couple of years ago we had a five
hundred billion dollar trade deficit
with China what that means is we import
500 billion more in products from China
than we export to China we have a
deficit of 500 billion dollars so it
seems that Trump who has the economics
understanding of a fruit fly thinks if
we cancel all trade we end up at zeroes
meaning the 500 billion deficit goes
away and it's like saving five hundred
billion dollars now this is not how
trade and economies work the 500 billion
trade deficit with China would go away
if we were to stop all trade with China
maybe it doesn't even really work that
way but then we would have a massive
deficit in terms of the products that we
all take for granted and then prices
would explode on a whole bunch of stuff
because our economy is based on cheap
stuff from China we would have to
there's a couple options if we stopped
trade with China on the one side for
importing we either have to import from
other countries the stuff we get from
China which just shifts the trade
deficit and it would explode demand for
these products in the new countries we
deal with bringing up the prices that
doesn't sound too good for American
businesses and individuals if we decide
to manufacture all of the stuff we get
from China internally I mean it would be
impossible but imagine that we did it
would take years to build those supply
chains but imagine we did it stuff would
cost way way more because the reason we
get these things from China is because
they're cheaper and our economy is based
on that and then you also have to
remember a ton of our businesses would
fail if we stopped exporting to China as
Trump says which would save us 500
billion as he puts it all of these
American businesses that are exporting
to China go under what do you think the
economic impact would be of that
unemployment on disposable incomes on
the stock prices as Trump might see
of these companies this is so absurd and
crazy and it is almost inconceivable
that an American president would have
such a lack of basic economic
understanding and Maria Bartiromo
through no fault of her own she's a
disastrous trump brown-noser through no
fault of her own she has exposed Trump
in this interview as completely and
utterly clueless not just on coronavirus
we knew that but also clueless on
economics to a degree that even those of
us following this for the last few years
would arguably be stunned and appalled
by no understanding whatsoever we're
gonna have more about this on the David
Pakman show Instagram
that's david pakman show on instagram
also on my personal Instagram it is
planting day today we are past the frost
here in Boston follow me at David Pakman
on Instagram to follow the urban
gardening intent there are a lot
happening in there in the next 24 hours
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today and drool a cough who's a
sociologist at the University of
Southern California also author of the
2017 book unprepared global health in a
time of emergency a great to have you
Andrew thanks for having me so here it's
become very and vogue now to point to
you know Bill Gates and his TED talk
about at some point we're going to have
a pandemic that were unprepared for and
so on and so forth and I think for our
conversation I want to focus in a little
more on on the nitty-gritty that you've
researched and and reported on and some
of the specifics maybe to start with we
can talk about this national stockpile
what are the origins of the national
stockpile what types of components are
there we we know of course about masks
and ventilators now but what's the kind
of genesis of that stockpile well
there's two parts to the story there the
very first idea of a stockpile of
essential supplies to be used in the
event of a catastrophic event took place
during the Cold War
so the civil defense agency built up
stockpiles all around the country of
essential medical supplies now by the
1970s those of course hadn't been used
fortunately we never had a nuclear war
that stockpile was closed down but the
idea was rekindled in the 1990s in
response to the threat of a bioterrorism
attack officials in the Clinton
administration were worried that
stockpiles of bio agents like smallpox
and anthrax that had been accumulated in
the Soviet Union had gone missing and
might be in the hands of terrorists
they began to think about the need for
stockpiles of biomechanical
countermeasures in the event of such an
attack so that really a got put in place
in the late 1990s in the early 2000s and
what what are examples of specifics that
are part of these stockpiles so
initially in response to the threat of a
bioterrorism attack a lot of the
elements of the stockpile were
specifically focused on possible terror
agents so there were nerve gas antidotes
there was millions of vials of smallpox
vaccine anthrax vaccines so a lot of
medications in cold storage eventually
antiviral medications in preparation for
pandemic influenza
there also were non non pharmaceutical
supplies for example and there's been a
lot of discussion of this ventilators
protective equipment that kind of thing
when it comes to the ventilator I don't
even really want to call it a debate but
what was for a while fear of a shortage
and what I would characterize as the
federal government's slow implementation
of distributing I mean I think that some
of those ventilators could have been
distributed far earlier at very little
cost if they end up not being necessary
okay you send them back what else sort
of should flesh out our understanding of
the ventilator piece specifically I mean
in terms of certainly creating new ones
we know that the manufacturing process
is not you have them in 48 hours we're
kind of now building up a supply which
will be manufactured over the next three
months but what what insight do you have
into the entire ventilator situation
yeah the I guess the to step back one to
step back a little bit the important
thing to keep in mind also is the
process of distribution so a lot of
planning and thought went into you know
once you have supplies available how do
you decide where they should go how do
you get them to the right places how do
you keep track of how many supplies of a
given item you have and where they are
among this the various stockpiles in
different parts of the country so one
piece of the story is of course do you
have enough of them and that's the
question you asked but another is how do
you get them to the places where they're
needed yes and and when it comes to that
is it on
realistic of me to think that in late
January or early February there were
likely the signals that would have
supported starting to deploy them at to
urban areas in some way or is it
unrealistic to think that that would
have been an appropriate time to do it
to be proactive yeah an important part
of stockpile planning is to put in place
the stockpiles of items where they're
needed as soon as you get a signal that
there might be a disaster on the way so
that's right as the World Health
Organization was putting every nation in
the world on alert in late January as
officials were beginning to counsel the
administration that there might be an
epidemic of a very dangerous disease on
the way in particular a respiratory
disease indeed that would have been the
time to start figuring out whether we
had enough ventilators and whether they
were in the right place so one more
thing on the stockpile thing and then I
want to move on to a few other things
Jared Kushner had this very strange
Orwellian moment where he said the
stockpile is our stockpile it's not the
state stockpile what I didn't that I
don't even know what to make of that in
the sense that well everybody I guess
unless you're in Guam or Puerto Rico
you're in one of the states like at we
are the states but is there anything
about the stockpiles origin that makes
that statement less Orwellian well it's
a very confused statement it doesn't
understand the whole premise of how
governmental preparedness has to work in
a federal system that like the United
States the whole presumption of a system
that is run by the federal government is
that states would make requests of the
federal government for the items when
they need them and that there would be a
elaborate and sophisticated coordination
between the federal government and the
states so it's not a competition between
the federal government and the states
it's not that it's belongs to the
federal government or us whatever Jared
Kushner meant by us but rather the real
effort is to figure out what the states
need and how can we get that material to
them yeah elaborate and sophisticated is
not matching up in my mind with a lot of
a lot of what we've seen so let's what
are some other ways in which as a planet
we are sort of underprepared for this
type of hundred year pandemic that we're
experiencing now and we know we don't
have a vaccine but that's a process you
need to sequence the virus and then
there's a process to go through most
optimistically there'd be you know
emergency use vaccines available in the
fall for healthcare workers and then
we're looking at 2021 we talked about
the ventilator distribution component
although fortunately the actual shortage
in the US has been has been minimal what
are some other ways that were
fundamentally underprepared for dealing
with something like this well I think
what we've seen in the last couple of
months is that you could have pretty
elaborate and sophisticated preparedness
plans in place and in fact under the
Obama administration very detailed
playbooks were put together for each
step of coordinated response to a
potential dangerous epidemic or pandemic
yes um but if you know if you have those
in place but you don't know you've got
the plans or you're not know you're not
aware of the plans you haven't practiced
them or you even don't take them
seriously
then when the actual event happens
you're not going to you're not going to
respond adequately but are there some
other bottlenecks that are very specific
in terms of I mean you know
international travel is very different
now than it was during the 1918 flu
pandemic and the speed with which the
pathogens can be moved around is a part
of it or what which systems are simply
not prepared to really deal with this at
the start yeah I mean I think that at
its really a variegated story around the
world I think you can you can look at
countries like South Korea or Germany
and see that although of course there's
not yet a vaccine and there's not even
as an effective medication there are
non-pharmaceutical interventions
especially combined with widespread
diagnostic testing that can do a decent
job of mitigating the disease threat I'm
obviously they can't cure it but so so
in certain countries that really have
thought carefully about how to do this
and have strong health systems in place
where it looks not so catastrophic in
other parts of the world where you don't
have competent government government
leadership you don't have a really
strong health system you have a lot of
economic inequalities that's where we
see the catastrophic event unfolding one
of the things I've been pointing out is
that the virus has exposed the
underlying fragility of a lot of the
systems that sometimes feel very very
solid and you know we could find two
three months ago we could have found a
number of indicators of the American
economy that weren't great right I mean
huge inequality and wages have been
stagnant etc but by the traditional
measures the economy was humming along
quite well high consumer confidence low
unemployment high stock market etc the
fragility that is exposed by a complete
hundred and eighty degree turn around in
just a few weeks for me has been one of
the most stunning things and I don't
know that you know the system we have
doesn't reward being proactive it's not
that profitable to be proactive but
that's been a huge thing for me yeah no
I completely agree not only is the the
health systems for fragile the supply
chain system is fragile the security of
what we call essential workers is
precarious one thing that preparedness
planners didn't think a lot about was
the how to deal with the economic after
effects of these non-pharmaceutical
interventions like social distancing
measures so I think countries that have
a much more resilient economic system in
place have turned out to be much better
prepared than countries like ours that
really focused on efficiencies at the
expense of resilience that's interesting
what we know from a medical perspective
with that certain countries were far
better prepared South Korea certainly
comes to mind but what which are the
countries that economically were much
better prepared well I think country I
would say that countries in which it was
taken for granted that you would you
would actually provide stable income so
you look at some of the Western European
countries that have instead of
furloughing workers or laying off
workers have kept workers up pretty much
on the job and employed through
government payments I think you need a
you need a an assumption of a social
welfare system to pass that kind of
legislation in an emergency context
which is something we of course don't
have here are there other countries what
other countries are at the top of the
list in terms of dealing with the
medical part
I mean what's happened in South Korea is
incredible they still don't have 300
deaths deaths they don't they're under
300 deaths which is just stunning given
that their first case was officially
found within hours of the first u.s.
case Germany has done well although they
had a far
larger outbreak and and I think it was
just a little more advanced by the time
they got around to it
there's a lot of debate about what's
happening in Sweden certainly a higher
death rate now but you're sort of taking
a bet that maybe the subsequent waves
won't be as deadly because you'll have
higher immunity we just don't know my
view is that we just won't know that for
a while what are the other countries
that medically have done the best yeah
and one thing I would agree with you
about the uncertainty about the outcome
in a place like Sweden but one thing I
would say is that insofar as a claim is
being made that we're kind of
accidentally following the Swedish model
in Sweden they have made sure that the
health systems are strong and that
people you know will have available
medical care so it's one thing to to let
things go without a plan in place and
it's another thing to sort of carefully
keep things less shut down than
elsewhere when you know that you're
gonna be able to provide serious medical
care for those who do get sick I think
the other countries to look at very
carefully although of course they're
different situations than the United
States our East Asian countries so
Taiwan Singapore places that experienced
stars were very proactive early on in in
January putting in place testing systems
contact tracing systems isolation
practices in some cases closing down
schools and businesses early and another
case in other cases not but it looks
like they those countries have for the
most part weather this much better than
the United States has one of the ideas
that's floated about when we look at
some of these other countries is that we
can't really do what some of those
countries do because they are far more
authoritarian now with the case of South
Korea South Korea ranks higher than the
United States on the democracy index
only slightly so but but they do and
certainly to say that South Korea
handled it because they're an
authoritarian system of government seems
completely false when it comes to some
other places
is there anything to the idea that not
all of these measures would be tolerable
in the United States politically well I
think you know again just to add to your
point a place like Germany there's no
way you could make an argument that
contemporary Germany is more
authoritarian than the United States
yeah but it really has to do with
competency trust and expertise proactive
government intervention and Trust by the
public in that intervention so it's not
so much a question of authoritarian
versus democratic but when you have a
when you have a liberal democratic
country what kind of system do you need
to have in place which of course we had
we had planned for such a system here
that wouldn't invade fundamental rights
the problem is we didn't implement that
plan last thing I want to touch on going
forward there may be a second and third
wave there may just be a second one this
first wave may never really diminish and
it may sort of go into the time where we
would potentially have a second wave we
don't know the timeline for a wide
widely available vaccine we don't
exactly know when any of the 70 or 80
possible treatments may turn up to work
very effectively there's economic
concerns we still aren't testing enough
what are you looking at and what would
be the the lowest hanging fruit to do
over the next six months well I think
what we what we're obviously going to
have a period of trial and error over
the next six months is we figure out
what works and what doesn't work because
obviously we won't have a vaccine in
that period or variant it's very
unlikely we would I think what we need
what what I'm looking at is just the
extent to which we're not flying blind
as we go forward how much are we
actually tracking what's going on and
proactively intervening before things
get bad again each time we try to lessen
our social distancing measures so the
more information we have the better and
the more that information ties into
actual rapid policy decisions the better
outcome we'll have are the over the next
few months so it sounds like at an
absolute minimum no matter what the
trajectory is going to be if we don't
have dramatically more testing we are
going to be short on the information we
need to really make informed decisions I
think that's right we need more we need
a dramatically more testing but we also
need to new to know what we're gonna do
with the results of those tests we
actually need a plan that links tests to
policies so it's not just the testing
but also acceptance of guidelines from
from a central coordinated government
effort that will lead to less bad
outcomes we've been speaking with Andrew
lay cough sociologist at the University
of Southern California also author of
the book unprepared global health in a
time of emergency Andrew I really
appreciate your time today thanks for
having me here the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
I have some video and audio for you
today that is truly the height of
absurdity when you talk about unelected
people in positions of huge power merely
because they are related to someone of
course our minds immediately should go
when I say that to Ivanka Trump and her
husband Jared Kushner Donald Trump's
son-in-law Jared Kushner was interviewed
by Time magazine earlier this week and
he was asked is it possible possible
that the November election could be
postponed because of coronavirus now
before I play the audio for you the
question is fraught the question is
fraught because it's not really up to
the Trump administration you'd have to
move heaven and earth to do it but you
could ask 50 states individually to
postpone their elections and there's a
question as to whether all states would
even be able to do it but even if you
managed to do that you could really only
delay the November election a few weeks
because in December the electors have to
certify that election unless you can
actually get what would likely need to
be a constitutional change or you know
maybe a Supreme Court decision it would
be insanely difficult to actually
postpone the November election it's also
a fraught question because Jared Kushner
should have no involvement their opinion
about this at all he's just Trump's
son-in-law he's been made an advisor
which is horrifying
but okay Jared Kushner is asked about
this now what I want to think about here
is whether this has been blown out of
proportion because there have been a lot
of apoplectic headlines saying Jared
Kushner is laying the groundwork to
postpone the presidential election are
trying to postpone the presidential
election I don't know that that's the
case necessarily looking at the clip
let's take a look at it there any
scenario including a second outbreak in
the fall where the elections need passed
November 3rd
that's too far in the future to tell
nothing that I'm aware of now but again
our focus right now is just not getting
the elections will happen on November
3rd it's not my decision to make so I'm
not sure I can commit one way or the
other but right now that's the plan and
again hopefully by the time we get to
you know September October November
we've done enough work with testing and
with and with all the different things
we're trying to do
so Jared says the plan is for November
3rd I can't commit to it but it's not
his position to commit he has no power
in when the election is held even Trump
essentially has no power and when the
election is held so I actually do
believe this was a little bit blown out
of proportion there's another idea which
is okay Jared can't do anything about it
but that's why Jared said it it's a
trial balloon to gauge reaction to it if
people go absolutely crazy in the end
jared has no say or involvement in this
so it's no big deal
on the other hand if Jared Kushner were
to say something and the reaction to it
is positive or not that negative then
this could be actually sort of a trial
balloon I just don't buy it I think what
happened here is that Jared Kushner's
wording is very clumsy and what we're
mostly reacting to is the fact that
Jared Kushner shouldn't be involved at
all in anything that's going on he
shouldn't be answering questions about
when the election is going to be held he
should be barred by nepotism laws from
even being involved with this
administration now don't get me wrong
Donald Trump may well be thinking of
trying to move the election he may end
up trying to move the election
I just don't think Jared Kushner's
comments or The Smoking Gun and I also
don't believe Trump would succeed in
doing it now in any case this blew up
and Jared Kushner ended up having to put
out a comment clarifying what he said
and he said quote I have not been
involved in nor am i aware of any
discussions about trying to change the
date of the presidential election so for
me the story is not Jared Kushner is
floating moving the election to me the
story is why are people talking to Jared
Kushner why is Jared Kushner involved in
things he knows nothing about Jared
Kushner has no authority Trump doesn't
even have the legal authority
move the election are they trying to are
they likely the Trump administration are
they likely to try to do everything they
can to maintain power of course voter
suppression disinformation propaganda
lying about their handling of
coronavirus lying about the state of the
economy lying about Joe Biden they're
going to do what we would colloquially
call trying to rig the election in their
favor but it's not going to be Jared
Kushner changing election day now what
can we do number one don't fall for the
propaganda number to push States to
adopt vote-by-mail number three get
people registered number four obviously
make sure that you vote one last thing
on postponing the election which i think
is important that and it should reduce
the hysteria a little bit if the
election is postponed imagine they
succeed right I don't see the path to it
but imagine they succeed and there's no
new president to inaugurate in January
of 2021 I'm just thinking out loud here
the Speaker of the House becomes the
president now right now that's Nancy
Pelosi democratic congresswoman Nancy
Pelosi I believe Trump will do anything
that he can to prevent Nancy Pelosi from
becoming president of the United States
now if you really want to get in the
weeds you could have a situation where
there's no election in November it
imagine I don't think it's good but
imagine there's no election in November
and because the election is postponed
you don't even have enough Congress
people to have them in DC with a quorum
to make Nancy Pelosi the president in
that case the next person in line
becomes the the next person in line to
be President would be the Senate
President Pro temp right now that's
Chuck Grassley this obviously gets very
dicey and that Republicans would likely
in that scenario try to prevent it from
going to Nancy Pelosi skip over her and
go to Grassley I'm merely going through
the motions here I don't believe this
would happen but there is a scenario
where the outcome of Trump's postponing
of the election makes Nancy Pelosi the
president until an election is held
there's no way Trump is going to take
any action that would make that likely
okay we literally have seen people argue
that it is okay to crowd together in
houses of worship churches because Jesus
is protecting the people from
coronavirus remember this lady a couple
of months ago six weeks ago driving out
of this Ohio parking lot is a woman who
just attended a church service with
dozens of other people including
children can I ask you about your
decision to go to church to be inside
that building I wouldn't be anywhere
else aren't you concerned you could in
fact other people if you get sick inside
I'm covered in Jesus's blood I'm covered
in Jesus all these people thank you very
much it turns out not only was that not
true
but churches while trying to get
coronavirus stimulus money are often
staying open causing new outbreaks of
disease New York pastor Fabian arias has
a parish that lost 44 people to
coronavirus that's not cases 44 deaths
to coronavirus bishop paul Eggen Steiner
from an Evangelical Lutheran Church
Network says that the pastors in their
network are reporting in some cases 25
to 50 percent of their congregations
have coronavirus in the south of the
United States we've seen more of these
huge evangelical churches stay open and
there's a whole bunch of examples
Kentucky there was an outbreak that
started and then but moved from the
church to GES aviation plant in
Madisonville 70 infections have been
traced back to a church in Sacramento
California the full list is not so
important but the point is churches have
been huge epicenters of outbreaks some
churches not all to be super clear some
churches have been the loudest advocates
against the stay at home orders wanting
exemptions from the large gathering bans
for example and yet at the same time
they want coronavirus money houses of
worship
have received hundreds of millions
certainly maybe even billions of dollars
under the Paycheck protection plan and
the reason is because searches are being
treated like any business or nonprofit
that needs funding so understand the
hypocrisy here churches want to be
exempt from stay-at-home orders because
they say we're not like any other
business or organization but they say we
are just like any other business
organization when it comes to PPP funds
now the truth is more complex many of
the churches that are seeking funds have
shut down or doing only online stuff
many churches in Massachusetts for
example fall under that umbrella so I am
not individually saying every church is
hypocritical because they are all
against shutdowns and all taking PPP
money that's not the case many of the
churches that got PPP funds are Catholic
churches and many Catholic churches have
been closing in accordance with state
guidelines but the special treatment has
to stop guys in the eyes of the law and
under government we've already said
churches likely shouldn't be nonprofits
and churches probably should be paying
property taxes now I have no problem if
the church has a school or a daycare
something that is truly a traditional
standard nonprofit
I'm fine looking at exemptions there but
the general blanket idea that by saying
you are a place of worship you pay no
taxes it has to end and in addition in
exchange for the privilege of not paying
taxes houses of worship are not supposed
to be political and often they are
rarely are there ever repercussions so I
just want consistency if you want to be
treated just like any other business and
get your PPP money and all of that well
then you don't get to say we are
different and we get to stay open as as
if we were an essential business why
would that be the case if you are
special and you get to stay open no
matter what and you get to not pay taxes
why do you also get the PPP funds and
then more urgently because really you
know I care more about lives than the
money component the issue of funding
taxes all of its important but it's not
urgent the issue of churches as a low
for coronavirus outbreaks that is both
important and urgent very much so and I
don't know at this point what can be
done there there are actually churches
that are deliberately being defiant
when it comes to coronavirus and staying
open and it has to stop because it's
spreading infection and as a result it
is spreading death so yesterday the
Eggman called in and the egg man says
Biden will win Florida because Trump
lost his former home state of New York
his home state is now Florida and old
folks in Florida don't like Trump and
they like Biden okay that was the Eggman
yesterday here's a different perspective
with a shot across the bow at the Eggman
saying it's actually Trump who's going
to win Florida take a listen yeah I
think Trump is gonna win in Florida and
the proof is recently we tried to get a
legalization of marijuana on the ballot
and we couldn't even get six hundred
thousand signatures to get marijuana on
the ballot and I know marijuana is way
more popular than Joe Biden is so either
there's not a lot of people that vote
democratic or the system is heavily
rigged but yeah okay so listen a
cannabis in Florida I don't think that
you can say that because they couldn't
get six hundred thousand signatures for
cannabis legalization in Florida it
means Joe Biden's going to lose and in
fact there are lots of remember Florida
has the fifth oldest population in the
country there are lots of older folks in
Florida who have no interest in seeing
marijuana legalized but they still are
on board with Joe Biden's ideas rather
than Donald Trump so my point is I don't
think we can glean anything about the
Florida presidential election because of
the failure of the cannabis signature
initiative that's my perspective right
now we have a great program coming up on
the bonus show today we are going to
talk about market manipulation in terms
of why we've seen the market do what it
is doing we will also talk about the
fear the
there will be chaos if electoral college
delegates are given free reign in the
November election and we will also talk
about Paul Manafort former Trump
campaign chairman Paul Manafort who was
going to be spending a bunch of time in
prison he is being released to his home
amid coronavirus concern how great for
him by the way what's happening with
Michael Cohen though we'll talk about
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access by
becoming a member at join pakman.com
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's a
full episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinka the app that
lets you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try bling kissed for free and save
25% off of a subscription when you go to
blink is comm slash david pakman i've
also included the link right underneath
this video